[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france en 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña desde argentina
lukas fauno gutiérrez el es periodista
escritor y activista vih-positivo lukas
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
france 24 es un placer tenerte hola
santiago muchísimas gracias por convivir
el espacio no por favor gracias a vos
locas una vez más bueno este mes de
junio estuvo marcado con lucas por un
aniversario sobre el que mucho no se
habla en algunos medios y en algunos
lugares sí pero no es no son muchos los
espacios que lo abordan y sobre este
tema vos has reflexionado y creo que
sacaste a la luz ideas pensamientos
incluso vivencias sumamente interesantes
para estos tiempos que corren estamos
hablando de que se cumplieron en junio
40 años desde que la organización
estadounidense de vigilancia y
prevención de enfermedades alertar al
mundo sobre lo que era en aquel momento
una nueva infección irá ligada
directamente a los homosexuales de hecho
uno de los primeros nombres no que tuvo
el sida antes de que fuera descubierto
el vih fue grid que en español serían
las siglas para
es enfermedades de inmunodeficiencia
relacionadas con los gays luego lucas en
determinado momento este virus comenzó a
tener rostros como más familiares no
heterosexuales blancos a cuatro décadas
lukas cambiaron los imaginarios en torno
al sida cambio algo en la respuesta
política y sanitaria
mira puedo decírtelo desde un lugar
quizás más redundante mente positivo de
que la respuesta es que hoy yo estoy
aquí vivo charlando con voz eso habla de
40 años también de acción y demás pero
lo que nos conviene lo que nos invoca
preguntar es por qué ha sucedido algo
porque ha habido activismos las
voluntades políticas no son espontáneas
responden a nuestras urgencias
activistas y todos nuestros activismos
de que nacen nacen de haber perdido
familiares amigos amigas amigos esos son
nuestros activismos las acciones que
nacen cuando han vulnerado nuestras
identidades nuestros derechos nuestros
cotidianos
entonces sin lugar a dudas que ha habido
avances pero los imaginarios siguen
siendo de el varón gay
no se habla por ejemplo de las niñas
niños y niñas nacidas nacidos y nacidas
con el virus que cuando hablamos de
personas verticales no se habla de las
feminidad es no se habla de las
poblaciones travestis y trans dios se
sigue teniendo al vih y al sida como
algo que ya pasó como algo que sigue
respondiendo un imaginario del varón gay
de los años ochentas y noventas pero
esto también porque es santiago porque
como estamos representadas las personas
vih positivas hoy en día en los medios
en las ficciones y en todo lo que vemos
seguimos siendo una narrativa de los 80
y 90 no hay representaciones culturales
me refiero series películas y demás que
hablen de cómo vivimos hoy en día
aparecemos en estas series y películas
solamente o para morir o para luchar o
para hacer una persona gay
viviendo con vih no se abrieron a nuevos
diálogos no se ha avanzado en la manera
no solo de representarnos sino de
dialogar nos seguimos pegados a ese
estigma y creo que por ejemplo está esta
situación de kobe mundial lo ha lo ha
explicitado obscenamente como algunos
virus importan y otros no así así vamos
a apuntar ahora a luca sabremos
precisamente de vih y de ccoo bits por
supuesto partimos desde la premisa de
que no son iguales no hay diferencias
fundamentales a lo que es nivel viral
por supuesto la medicina no sabrá
explicar por supuesto mejor que yo no
pero si hay puentes ciertos puntos que
se abren y sobre los cuales se puede
reflexionar no a vos lo has hecho si
pensamos por ejemplo en ese señalamiento
no con el que comenzamos esta entrevista
que ocurrió hace 40 años pero pasamos al
cob y como bien dijiste en alguna
oportunidad lo primero que escuchamos
sobre este virus fue la búsqueda de un
culpable no un responsable ya sea una
sopa de murciélagos un país no lo
primero que apareció claramente fue el
señalamiento y la
habilidad de alguien no la misma
estructura giraba en torno al sí de hace
40 años verdad el culpable era el
homosexual
si el homosexual eran las 4 h era el
homosexual las personas hemofílicas pero
y no manos y haitianos también y también
se hablaba de trabajadoras sexuales o
sea esta idea de que todo reside en la
otra edad es la que no se expulsa es la
que nos exonera es la que eclesiástica
teóricamente te diría nos libera del
pecado entonces todo esto reside en
otras en otros y en o3 y claramente
cuando hablamos de cualquier situación
pandémica claramente cuando hablamos de
cualquier situación que emboque derechos
y más la respuesta es colectiva por
ejemplo ahora qué está pasando con kobe
y las vacunas las vacunas están quedando
en pocos países bueno si todo el mundo
no tiene acceso a una respuesta ante lo
que es kobe el virus va a persistir y
por qué
hablo de vacunas y hablo de patentes
porque hace poco vimos como el hashtag
en trending topic en distintas redes era
líder en las patentes bueno las personas
vías positivas hace muchos años
que estamos exigiendo no solo que se
liberen las patentes sino que el sistema
farmacológico el sistema médico el
sistema farmacéutico y demás
se ha revisado se ve a la ética de la
salud como puede ser que las personas
estamos hablando de 40 años decida si
vemos en la línea histórica del virus
desde su aparición y demás a presión
pública sobre todo pasaron muchos años
hasta que aparecieron las primeras
médicas ya nos pasaron muchos años hasta
que algún presidente como ronald reagan
habló de esto porque es una decisión
política ese tiempo porque en ese
momento supuestamente no quienes morían
hemofílicos homosexuales haitianos
trabajadoras sexuales y más por eso no
se habló en cambio ahora estamos viendo
obvio con gran alegría y esperanza es
que en un año en un año y medio hubo una
respuesta a kobe que se está
desarrollando totalmente mal era
muchísimo porque yo soy parte de eso
también pero me hace mirar atrás y
pensar y por qué se tardó tanto para una
respuesta con respecto al vih sida y
tiene que ver con este imaginario como
decíamos recién de quien lo tiene
o sea porque lo tiene que suceder
entonces cuando hablamos de vih y cuando
hablamos de sida no estamos hablando
solamente de un virus
fisiológico literalmente estamos
hablando de estructuras sociales estamos
hablando de una respuesta o quizás una
no respuesta política nunca bueno vos
mismo recién lo planteaba se liberen las
patentes no es un reclamo que tanto a
vos como muchísimas otras personas
vienen sosteniendo hace décadas por el
acceso a los retrovirales en los años 90
el mundo del vih positivo fue pionero a
la hora de pedir esto que estamos
hablando no la flexibilización de la
patente es poder producir a precios
accesibles los medicamentos un grito que
hoy como decíamos se traslada al pedido
por la liberación de lo que son las
vacunas contra el cob y 1990 larguísima
experiencia en esta militancia un poco
lo adelantaba no pero te lo quiero
preguntar de manera concreta no qué rol
juegan acá los laboratorios las empresas
nosotros solo laboratorios son los
laboratorios son los estados digo porque
si no siempre estamos orbitando en la
punta del iceberg y tiene que ver con
como los estados también deben fomentar
su investigación nacional sus espacios
nacionales está esta eterna situación de
mantra no de que salva el estado o el
mercado no bueno personalmente yo lo que
creo que tiene que haber un diálogo
entre todo y cuando hablamos de patentes
no estamos hablando solamente de las
patentes como decía recién estamos
hablando de ética
estamos hablando de farmacológica
estamos hablando de estados que
responden sobre todo a intereses pero
detrás esos intereses están en nuestras
vidas está nuestro cotidiano en la
historia del vih y el sida podemos ver
en estas ficciones que yo decía por
ejemplo hay una cambia fascina que es la
película 120 pulsaciones por minuto que
abordan no solamente cuando faltaba
medicación sino cuando las medicaciones
estaban probándose nuevas y todo
responde a estos intereses entonces no
puede
y ahora que estamos hablando de liberen
las patentes solamente hablemos de kobe
de liberen las patentes tiene que ser un
grito estructural porque así como yo
también estoy hablando ahora de vih y
decida qué pasa con las personas con
hepatitis que pasaban las personas con
tuberculosis qué pasa con las personas
con distintas situaciones de salud de
nuevo en ningún momento
santiago de durante esta charla hemos
hablado en y de vih universidad ni de
acogida hablamos de estructuras sociales
claro hablamos de respuestas de las
faltas de respuestas hablamos de
situaciones políticas y éticas porque si
no de nuevo nos vamos a quedar en vih en
sida en kobe y no tenemos que repensar
los sistemas de salud no puede ser que
esta nueva pandemia esté sacudiendo al
mundo y no nos haga repensar y re
preguntarnos cómo son las distribuciones
de acceso a la salud o sea cuando yo
tomo en medicación vih yo para tomar
medicación vih tengo que tener un
trabajo un techo una casa un vaso de
agua potable
no podemos objetar al vih y el sida
pensando que es solamente
pastilla en argentina la ley actual de
vih desde el año 2009 90 estamos camino
a que por tercera vez caiga el estado
parlamentario del proyecto de ley porque
necesitamos una nueva ley una nueva ley
que incluya y te heces de tuberculosis
hepatitis virales y demás porque de
nuevo no es vih no es sida no es kobe es
nuestra sociedad completa son nuestras
decisiones políticas y de salud lo que
nos queda un minuto aproximadamente pero
no quiero despedirte de sheen antes
antes preguntarte lo siguiente no crees
que de haber sido las sociedades y por
supuesto también los gobiernos entidades
sanitarias más empáticas no con los
reclamos que ustedes vienen sosteniendo
desde hace décadas quizás la convivencia
con el commit 19 no sería mejor
hubiésemos llegado a quizás parados de
otra manera mejor preparados sin lugar a
duda imagínate que si hubiesen escuchado
nuestro reclamo de hace años de liberen
las patentes si hubiesen escuchado
nuestra urgencia de hace años de lo mal
que están los sistemas de salud como
hubiésemos comenzado esta pandemia como
las hemos comenzado seguramente con otro
sistema
y de acceso a vacunas y demás hubiésemos
comenzado esta pandemia seguramente con
un sistema hospitalario de otra manera o
sea por eso me parece tan importante
recuperar esto y no solamente como te
decía recién quedarnos en lo superficial
no con la cura no alcanza como persona
había hecho positiva no exigimos
solamente la mejor medicación o el mejor
sistema médico exigimos la cura pero
bueno es algo que se retroalimenta con
todo el sistema que te mencionaba recién
absolutamente lucas fauna gutiérrez
muchísimas gracias ha sido un placer
esta entrevista contigo muchísimas
gracias a ustedes y bueno vamos por la
curación ojalá así sea
lucas te agradecemos una vez más ya
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto con gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]